[Música]
en Brasil Después de tres días de
intensas lluvias las inundaciones
devastan cerca de 30 localidades del Sur
del país es el caso de Batista donde los
habitantes Todavía no saben cuándo
volverán a sus casas les traemos la
historia
la estrella del fútbol brasileño Pelé
está en cuidados paliativos en Qatar
afición futbolistas la FIFA ola conmebol
dedican sus pensamientos al futbolista
hablamos con el periodista Patricio de
la barra quien conoció en persona la
leyenda
ante la llegada del invierno en Europa y
frente a la crisis energética derivada
de la guerra en Ucrania el presidente
francés pidió calma la población macron
aseguró que el gobierno está preparado
para situaciones extremas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de frank34 en español Soy Rosa Pérez +
deu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Brasil porque
las inundaciones causadas por tres días
de Fuertes lluvias han dejado ciudades
completamente devastadas es el caso de
Batista en el sur del país donde los
habitantes esperan que baje el nivel del
agua para regresar a sus hogares Andrés
granadillo tiene los detalles
las Fuertes lluvias en Brasil dejan a su
paso devastación en Sao Joao Batista en
el estado Santa Catarina el 95% del
municipio quedó afectado viviendas
vehículos y casas quedaron dañadas lo
mismo ocurrió en otras 30 ciudades del
estado
el agua llegó hasta este tejado de aquí
yo estaba al otro lado de la calle en la
casa de mi vecino y vi como el agua
llegaba hasta la puerta había algunas
cosas que había puesto encima de mi
cocina pero la alacena se vino abajo con
todo batidora licuadora todo se fue al
suelo
y papel
los habitantes desesperados andan por
las calles con sus enseres mojados una
de las afectadas tuvo suerte en
comparación con otras personas que lo
perdieron todo y pues Facebook hubo
gente que pasó peor ahora pasó un señor
de edad y su casa quedó destruida sin
duda hay otros que tuvieron peores
estragos
la crecida de las aguas fue de 1,6
metros el equipo de protección civil
declaró el estado de emergencia mientras
el gobierno local creó un comité de
crisis
muchos se refugiaron en un albergue
mientras están a la espera de que la
crisis pase y puedan volver a sus casas
con lo poco que les queda tras La
tempestad viene la calma pero también la
incertidumbre que trae consigo la
tragedia
continuamos en Brasil porque la leyenda
del fútbol brasileño Pelé está en
cuidados paliativos en el hospital
Albert Einstein de Sao Paulo después de
que la quimioterapia ya no tuviera el
efecto deseado en el tratamiento de su
cáncer de colon en Qatar aficionados
futbolistas la FIFA y la conmebol le
dedicaron sus pensamientos ahora para
analizar la importancia de pelea en la
historia del fútbol Contamos con el
periodista Patricio de la barra Patricio
Buenas tardes empecemos por analizar la
importancia de Pelé pero en el ámbito
deportivo
Hola muy buenas tardes Rosa y a todos
quienes te siguen la verdad es que
pelees Para mí fue uno de los mayores
iconos del fútbol mundial un jugador que
superó todas las marcas se recuperó
marcó más de mil goles incluso estuvo en
diversas partes del planeta yo no conocí
en Chile incluso deja pequeño y él ya
era un gran Astro en 1958 recordemos que
venció ese primer mundial y de ahí para
adelante se tornó para mí el mejor
jugador de o el mejor atleta de la
historia del fútbol mundial participó en
otros mundiales el 62 posteriormente
después estuvo en el mundial 66
Lamentablemente salió lesionado fue
campeón en 1970 Y a partir de ahí
comenzó a abandonar el fútbol pero no
dejaba de participar de torneos que eran
creados en el mundo entero Incluso en
África llegó a paralizar una guerra
entre dos países para ver a Pelé decir
algo mayor algo que ningún otro
deportista seguramente lo ha alcanzado
en el mundo en estos momentos él se
encuentra recluido ahí en el hospital
Albert Einstein y está en no todo bien
cuidado intensivo está en una sala común
incluso la hija Flavia recientemente
criticó un poco a la prensa por esta
preocupación mayor con respecto a la
salud de del Astro el exastro del fútbol
diciendo que lo actuaban en forma
maliciosa esperando lógicamente un
desenlace que todavía no se ve venir
porque él está claro
defendiéndose de un cáncer al al colon
que se desparramó por otras otras otros
órganos pero que todavía está lúcido y
muy bien incluso respondió al homenaje
que le rindieron en Qatar no
Y usted Patricio destacaba algunos de
los hitos no de Pelé fuera de lo
estrictamente futbolístico no como
jugador a nivel social y político Por
qué destacó su figura
bueno él llegó a ser el ministro incluso
de deportes de uno de los gobiernos
después de la de la democratización de
Brasil y Tuvo una intensa participativa
participación muy activa en cuanto a los
derechos humanos y a los derechos de las
de los menores principalmente cuando él
marcó el milésimo gol ahí en el estadio
maracaná recordemos que él pidió que se
cuidase de los de los menores
abandonados y que estaban en las calles
de Brasil y bueno y él siempre tuvo la
participación muy activa en cuanto a a
defender el derecho de los de los
menores y de incluirlos de cierta forma
utilizando el fútbol para ellos él fue
el que destacó a roviño a Diego y a una
serie de otros jugadores llevándolos al
Santo muy pequeños y brindando entre
todo tipo de apoyo y Esto fue
posteriormente utilizado para llevar a
Neymar y otros jugadores que se han
destacado en el en el concierto mundial
es decir una preocupación que él tiene
no solamente por la parte futbolística
como también por el bienestar de de la
gente menor en Brasil no y usted que lo
conoció en persona como es en la
distancia corta Pelé Bueno la verdad es
que soy muy accesible yo creo que una de
las grandes figuras en las cuales yo lo
entrevisté en cuatro oportunidades
Incluso en una de ellas y cuando
llevamos un diario que trabajaba la
tercera la hora tenía un programa para
llevar a menores eh de algunos equipos
de acá de Brasil y él colaboró
especialmente en eso incluso estuvo
presente en uno de estos torneos que se
llamaban camino a la fama decir una
persona muy accesible siempre estuvimos
eh contacto permanente y donde nos
encontramos Bueno nos encontrábamos
porque ahora últimamente lamentablemente
no está dando entrevistas pero siempre
trabajó de la mejor forma posible no
Patricio de la barra se nos acaba el
tiempo desafortunadamente pero
muchísimas gracias por compartir estas
experiencias y su conocimiento con
nosotros
y este viernes las autoridades de
Venezuela y el gigante energético
estadounidense Chevron acordaron
reanudar las operaciones petroleras en
territorio venezolano recordemos que la
semana pasada Washington anunció la
licencia agebrón vinculada al avance de
las conversaciones entre oficialismo y
oposición venezolana sin embargo la
medida llega en plena crisis energética
desatada por la guerra en Ucrania y las
sanciones occidentales a Moscú
la firma de un contrato petrolero que
entierra parte de las tensiones entre
Estados Unidos y Venezuela autorizado
por Washington este acuerdo comercial
con la empresa estadounidense Chevron le
permite reanudar sus actividades en el
país aún sometido a sanciones económicas
por parte de Estados Unidos condenada al
aislamiento desde la reelección de
Nicolás maduro en 2018 Caracas vive una
crisis económica y social por ello el
gobierno venezolano aplaudió esta
posible reanudación de las exportaciones
de crudo a Norteamérica a nombre del
gobierno bolivariano del presidente
Nicolás Maduro Moro a nombre de todo el
equipo de pedevesa y de la clase
trabajadora
celebramos
la firma de estos contratos y
le agradecemos a todos los que han
participado
obligado a prescindir de los
hidrocarburos rusos desde el inicio de
la guerra en Ucrania Estados Unidos se
plantea recurrir a Caracas una decisión
facilitada por la firma de un acuerdo la
semana pasada entre el gobierno
venezolano y la oposición en el exilio
un proceso que tiene como objetivo la
organización de elecciones libres en el
país vamos a dialogar
porque nosotros queremos una elecciones
libres en Venezuela
libres de sanciones libres de medidas
coercitivas unilaterales o hay
elecciones libres de sanciones o hay
elecciones libres de sanciones Ahí está
El dilema elecciones libres quieren
justas y transparente elecciones libres
de sanciones
nos espera que este regreso de la
petrolera estadounidense chevere una
Venezuela revolucione el mercado mundial
del crudo el país representa actualmente
el 1% de la producción mundial de oro
negro
y en Ucrania la Navidad estará marcada
por la guerra entre otras cosas sin
muchas luces ni adornos debido a la
crisis de energía en el país por otro
lado los aliados europeos también temen
escasez energética derivada de las
sanciones impuestas a Moscú el
presidente francés Emmanuel macrón pidió
calma y se mostró seguro frente a las
medidas adoptadas por su gobierno para
contrarrestar los posibles cortes de
energía Manuela Cano nos amplia una
plaza vacía Y una promesa de austeridad
chef Recibió la temporada navideña sin
luces ni adornos el centro de la capital
ucraniana suele ser gala de un enorme
árbol de navidad de más de 30 metros
esta vez ante los ataques rusos a la
infraestructura ucraniana su tamaño se
verá reducido a más de la mitad y estará
adornado con símbolos del ejército
ucraniano una muestra simbólica de la
crisis energética que vivió Ucrania y
Europa la llegada de un invierno inusual
preocupa al viejo continente en donde se
han anunciado posibles cortes de
Electricidad Y aunque el panorama parece
gris las autoridades de algunos países
europeos hacen un llamado a la calma No
entren en pánico eso no tiene sentido
hay un trabajo legítimo realizado por el
gobierno para prepararse para casos
extremos que es por supuesto la
necesidad de cortar la electricidad
durante algunas horas en el día Es
normal que el gobierno se prepare para
un caso extremo porque como nos han
demostrado los últimos años a veces
sucede lo impensable
en paralelo Europa Busca soluciones
Bélgica inaugura la mayor planta de
almacenamiento de energía eléctrica de
Europa continental afuera de una pequeña
ciudad belga estos contenedores son
capaces de satisfacer la demanda máxima
del país un paso hacia la transición
energética hasta ahora la capacidad de
producir rápidamente significaba muchas
centrales eléctricas de petróleo
centrales eléctricas de gas que
activamos en cualquier momento con este
nuevo tipo de Central eléctrica es
posible prescindir por completo de los
combustibles fósiles ante una posible
crisis energética la comisión europea
planteó Establecer un tope para los
precios de gas en toda la Unión Europea
una determinación que ha generado
choques entre los ministros de energía
de muchos de los países miembros y Rusia
y belarus dan nuevas muestras públicas
de su estrecha cooperación en este caso
en el ámbito militar este sábado el
ministro de defensa de Rusia sergeygu se
entrevistó con su homólogo bielorruso
Víctor kremlin y con el presidente
Alexander lukashenko se conocen pocos
detalles de las reuniones Pero ha
trascendido que ambas partes acordaron
nuevos puntos de seguridad regional
recordemos que Minsk ha descartado
entrar militarmente en la Guerra de
Ucrania Pero ha cedido su territorio al
ejército ruso para llevar a cabo la
invasión del territorio ucraniano
y en otras noticias china comienza a
relajar su política sanitaria de cero
covid que fue el objeto de las protestas
de la semana pasada y es que las
manifestaciones contra las restricciones
fueron tan fuertes que en algunas
incluso pidieron la renuncia del
presidente algo que no se había visto en
los últimos años vamos con el informe
estas fueron las protestas que
desconcertaron al mundo después de tres
años de encierros masivos y pruebas
constantes los ciudadanos frustrados
salieron a la calle en manifestaciones
generalizadas que el país No había visto
en décadas Beijing ha señalado que una
flexibilización amplia de la política
cero covid podría estar en marcha ya que
las ciudades se preparan para suavizar
las restricciones esta decisión fue
recibida con alivio por parte de la
población
creo que la gente se alegra de que se
suavice la política porque reduce el
impacto en la vida de las personas
todos mis amigos piensan que tras la
reapertura Seguiremos necesitando cierta
protección diaria y que deberemos
abastecernos de algunos medicamentos en
casa así si alguien tiene síntomas no
tendrá que ir al hospital
el presidente del Consejo europeo
la cuestión de las
en su visita a Beijing si acusó los
jóvenes frustrados de desatar las
protestas y sugirió que ya que la cepa
omicron es menos letal las políticas del
país podrían suavizarse la
flexibilización de las normas contra el
covid 19 en algunas ciudades fue bien
acogida por la Organización Mundial de
la Salud
nos complace saber que las autoridades
chinas están Ajustando sus estrategias
actuales y realmente tratan de calibrar
ahora las medidas de control que
necesitan para este virus con las vidas
los sustentos y los Derechos Humanos de
las personas en las comunidades
las nuevas políticas podrían incluir más
vacunaciones pruebas no obligatorias
en lugar de cierres masivos y la
flexibilización de las normas sobre el
transporte público pero por ahora los
residentes aún no han presenciado un
cambio sobre el terreno Muchísimas
gracias por su atención sigan con más
información en frank34 y 34.com
[Música]